t'es pas chanteuse tu saurais je serai
psychiatre jeu j'écouterai les patients
et je leur prescrit des anti choisir un
mot pour décrire des géniteurs
je dirai un mot dans le contexte dans le
contexte de ce métier je dirais allié à
lire
pourquoi parce que c'est mon année parce
que dans mes doutes d'artistes aidant
mais dans mes joies d'artistes même les
gens les plus proches de toi dans ta
famille dans tes amis vu qu'ils sont pas
aisées voulut pas dans le même contexte
émotionnel parce que on est quand même
produit quand même un truc un peu à part
est extraordinaire donc il faut des
alliés dans ce milieu dans ce métier des
gens qui te comprennent à qui tu peux
dire les choses sans avoir à les
expliquer et el bass et la personne avec
qui je partage tout ça il ya long
échange sur ça donc je dirais même que
je devais n'utilisez plus qu'un tel
réseau social ce serait serait instagram
jeu
mon réveil je mange je dors à g
non je trouve que c'est un endroit
particulièrement créatif on peut
s'étonner création de son univers
j'adore quitte à surprendre beaucoup de
monde mais bon chroniqueur préféré axer
pmp c'est benjamin cassaigne parce qu'on
a un peu de la même génération en ce
moment il est une pâte en moins là donc
comme ça et cela ramène un peu moins
mais c'est quelqu'un que j'apprécie
parce qu'il est cool dans la vie etc ou
l'école son père et j'adore son père
voilà c'est un petit à petit clin d'oeil
pour benjamin castaldi est bien bon
chroniqueur préfère je ne veux également
pas vexer les autres parce qu'on
s'entend plutôt bien tout le temps faim
envahie accès valérie bénaïm que je
connais depuis un certain temps et avec
laquelle je pense qu'on a réussi à
établir une jolie complicité
j'étais un homme convaincu leonardo
dicaprio très simple donc je n'avais pas
été humoriste tu arrêter au chômage j'ai
de leur monarque à 1 26 dollar ou six
multi est à refaire tu devais être fan
ce serait de ce serait je suis déjà
tonnes donc si je devais non je suis fan
donc si je devais être fan encore plus
fan je veux dire que fan mais qu'est ce
que c'est plus fun que fan en faire la
fin d'année sont pas des questions
instruments de musique
le djembé danse johnny jamais dire une
bêtise
si j'étais une chanson de johnny au mari
si tu savais tout le mal qu'ils me
retirer
alors
c'est tout comme